so i tweeted the other day jokingly if  trump were president right now he'd come  out and he'd say i just spoke to putin  he tells me the invasion's fine i asked  him did you do anything wrong and he  said no sir everything is fine and he  said it very strongly and i believe him  now that was like kind of a joke but in  all seriousness if trump was president  during the russian invasion of ukraine  he first would have just insisted on  like i don't know that putin's really  going to invade i just don't think so  putin's really smart  putin would have invaded trump still  would have said his stupid  putin smart and he's savvy and he's a  genius but then  everybody would have gone to trump and  said uh sir  you can't keep supporting putin and then  trump would have backed off like he did  and said we've got to be on the side of  the ukrainians he eventually would have  had no choice but he would have been  dragged kicking and screaming away from  supporting vlad